the first lesson today in about sort of
having patience for your dream
is you have to work on it every single
day
for at least 30 minutes or don't fool
yourself that it's gonna happen
i'm gonna honor this process sort of
it's a little samurai mentality you know
it's like
i'm gonna honor that this is difficult
because that is precisely what's needed
if you want to deal with self-doubt you
absolutely must start entering each day
as more intentional of a human
need motivation watch the top 10 of
believe nation because i love it
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you are
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best brendon burchard and my
take on his top 10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one work on your dream
daily the first lesson today in about
sort of having patience for your dream
is you have to work on every single day
for at least 30 minutes or don't fool
yourself that's gonna happen
you know we all hope that one day we'll
get a bunch of free weekends or a month
off or three months off and that's when
we'll finally start working towards our
thing
you got to do it every day where that
means you research every day you read
every day you study every day you take a
course every day
or you actually create everything on
that thing
every day you're just working at it book
authors they write every day not all of
them
but a lot of the greats wrote every
single day right and it's just
forcing ourselves to really be in the
game now not everybody writes every day
not even needs to create every day some
people are just having a marvelous
18 days and they've written the greatest
book of all time
but that rarely happens it rarely
happens
and those folks tend to be like masters
or savants or geniuses
regular folks myself included i got to
work every day towards my dreams
every day i honed in something about
this and if you didn't know something
about me i do everything
in this business right i'm shooting this
video right now but i mean i picked the
materials
for this thing i chose the fonts i
designed all the pages
i mean i wrote the back cover the front
cover
the inside stuff it's like i do the
projects of
my dreams and that's what keeps me
creatively fired up and engaged you know
rule number two let go let go
of the baggage you're never
going to touch the full rim of your
potential if you're weighted down by
baggage
from your elementary school years your
high school years
your college years these last four years
listen the last chapters of the book
you've gone through them
you finished them you flipped the page
you got a new chapter here
and you have to be willing to break from
the past
to have the future you so desperately
desire
you have to have the courage to allow
yourself
to honor the past as it was to forgive
those who need to be forgiven
to forgive yourself and to acknowledge
that
everything led you to this point now
everything
those crappy times those times when
you're depressed
those times when you gave up on yourself
those times when someone else gave up on
you
those times that you gave up on others
the times that you quit
the times that you failed the times that
you felt so small you were embarrassed
those times don't live in this moment
and the more of those times that you
cultivate in your mind and you ruminate
on
and you think and you self-talk on and
you revisit in your mind
the more disempowering times from the
past
hurtful times from the past
failures from the past that you keep
running
in your head what that is doing is that
is taking up the very
free space necessary for the bold ideas
to come in
it's taking up the space for the very
needed white space for creativity
to come in for the dreams to come in
for the best you to speak through from
like it's hard for you to live an
authentic and true and vulnerable and
real life
if you're always speaking through your
baggage if you're always thinking
through
your baggage and you guys know what i'm
talking like everyone's got different
baggage
maybe your maybe your baggage is your
divorce
or that last job they are not relevant
today
and the only reason they're relevant
today is if either you allow them to be
relevant
from those situations or those persons
revisiting you or you're running the
same old story
you're running the same old excuses yeah
i can't do this because
i suck at relationships no you sucked
your relationships 10 years ago
well i can't do this because you know i
i failed
yeah six months ago today's a new day
homie like
you gotta access this day dude this day
is fresh this day is clean this day
woke up showered ready prepped for you
by the universe or spirit or
god or luck or cosmos whatever you want
to call it this day
says to you when you wake up in the
morning the day whispers to you do not
fear me for i have been brought here for
you
you don't fear the day that day has been
brought here for you
rule number three know other people's
goals
you never know a person if you don't
know their goals
and if you don't know their goals you're
never going to be a great friend
you'll never be their great lover their
great supporter their great
family member and it's weird though
because most people actually don't know
other people's goals i'll ask family
members to say what what's your sister's
goals
you know she wants to be a dancer okay
what kind of dancer
when what does she want to do with that
career is the short term is it long term
like
you have to really get into people's
goals to understand their heart
and so that's what i want you to do is
if you want to be a great spouse to
somebody
you got to re-engage and say hey what do
you want at this stage of your life
because i know i know what you used to
want then we had kids but where are you
at now
and you gotta get that conversation with
your partner and say hey listen
i know we've been through a couple of
weird months where we just haven't
really
felt each other out it's like let's just
do some personal development like
what do you really want to do right now
at this stage of your life because you
have to understand
when i say this stage of your life
that's very specific
meaning a lot of people's goals change
and it changes like every three months
every year every three years so if you
haven't had the conversation
with the important people in your life
recently about what your goals are
and about what their goals are then i'm
telling you you're just skimming at the
surface
because if you don't support other
people's dreams how can you ever have a
deep relationship with them
and if you don't share your dreams and
your heart and your desire with other
people
how can they possibly help you meet that
hunger how can they possibly
help you become the best version of you
if you haven't shared it
so you also have to be very honest with
what's your real thoughts what's your
real feelings what's your real dreams
what do you really want at this stage of
your life
with all the important people around you
it's one of my favorite things to do
with high performers to say
okay do all the people around you know
what you really want right now
are they clear on what your goals are
are they clear about how they can
support that or how much you want them
to be involved in it
it's like a lot of people start their
own business but they don't tell the
other people around them
what that business is what it requires
how they love their support
and so we all go it alone and isn't
going it alone the opposite of having
healthy supportive relationships so
first thing you got to do if you want
better relationships
get to know other people's goals rule
number four
hire faster many of you you've been
waiting to hire that first virtual
assistant
or that person to help you with the
house so you can focus on your business
who can support you with the kids or
somebody who can you know come in and
help just clean the house some of you
waiting to hire that manager that ceo
that ceo
and i'm here to tell you do it like set
your
quarter one goals of 2019 to hire the
team that you need
don't finish quarter one without the
team that you need in place
trained and going for some of you that
might be a hundred employees
some of you that's ten i don't know what
your situation is but i'm here to tell
you
higher sooner higher better
my friend evan carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number five live your intentions if
you want to deal with self-doubt
you absolutely must start entering each
day
as more intentional of a human because
the issue is one of the reasons we doubt
ourselves is because we're just all over
the place
you know sometimes you're cool in this
situation but you're dumb in that
situation sometimes
you don't do well here but you do well
here and what happens is so many people
they're going through the motions or
they're just showing up in life
every single day and they're reacting
and because they're always reacting
they don't have a character they haven't
determined
who am i really who am i going to act
like in this situation
who i would behave like in this
situation how i'm going to treat people
in this
situation because they haven't shown up
intentional enough
and sought to live out that intention
they feel a lot of discord
in life like they don't know who they
are because they just keep showing up
and reacting to what's there but
guess what what's there is always
different the world is always changing
people are always changing situations
are always changing
so if all you're ever doing is showing
up and reacting i guess i'll just go
through it and see how it goes
you're never forming an intentional
character so of course you doubt
yourself
because every situation is different and
you can never have certainty in that
but you can have strength inside if from
now on you wake up every day and you say
okay
i'm gonna be these three words today and
you just set the words you say okay
i'm gonna be fun i'm gonna be playful
and be kind
and that day you are fun playful and
kind and the next day you say okay i'm
gonna be patient today
i'm gonna be thoughtful and i'm gonna be
appreciative and you're patient
thoughtful and appreciative you do that
over and over and over again set an
intention for who to be
be that set an intention be that set an
intention
be that and you do that in more
situations in your life
and more days and more weeks and more
months and more years and one day you
wake up and you're like
you're confident in self because you
know that you can direct your mind
and your emotions and your body to be
the person who you really want to be
the more often you do that the more real
genuine self confidence will come into
your life
rule number six practice visualization
the most important thing i know this
sounds so
so silly but common sense is not always
common practice
and that's why so many potentially great
people fail to ever achieve
their potential and that's this listen
you have to get your visualization game
down visualization that means listen
when i wake up when i got a dream
i wake up in the morning before i get
out of bed i close my eyes i just see it
happening a little bit and i'll lay in
bed and let my
mind and my body stir up a little bit of
excitement
or sometimes even anxiety about seeing
the actual thing that i want
happen that was for me at one part of my
life seeing myself on stages
speaking and training to people one part
of my life it was seeing
my book come out and seeing it on the
new york times bestseller list or
seeing it on the amazon bestseller list
it was sometimes
seeing myself coaching major celebrities
or sitting side by side with an oprah
winfrey or tony robbins or
larry king all of which i've been able
to do it was because i
visualized what i really wanted but
here's the thing
it's not just visualization that's like
the first part
it's also affect we talk about high
performance and in psychology about this
thing called affect which is basically
feelings and emotions
i i want you to allow yourself to
literally not just kind of
casually see it like put yourself there
and
feel it and sense it and see and feel it
and
drink it in like really take in the
ambiance the circumstance you
like really visualize and feel
what you are seeing that's so key i mean
as silly as this is i literally would
lay there and i'm like okay
if i'm gonna feel like feel like fill
out the ideal
thing what what questions would i ask to
really get it going i just start
literally seeing myself at my desk in
the morning
feeling filling out the high performance
planner thinking about other people
worldwide filling out at the same time
as me and
knowing that i got this tribe of people
on this path
of trying to be their best with me and
imagining people coming up and says oh
my gosh
you know brandon you completely changed
my morning you completely changed my
weekly routine you completely changed my
life because i never tracked my habits
before
i never assessed my balance every single
week between family
friends work finances adventure learning
etc everything every tool that we put in
here i could just imagine someone come
up and say brandon i really appreciate
that part
and i literally just thought about it
because i wanted it
to feel like you know i was excited for
the project otherwise what
look how easy it is to diminish anything
in our lives well it's just a book it's
just a planner it's just a
it's just a video it's just a cosmetic
line it's just a beauty thing it's just
that like we all diminish our dreams
we make excuses and we make our dreams
like ah
we throw it away because we're scared to
feel it you know what i'm saying
it's easier to throw it away that's no
big deal avoid it not no problem
and we mess up i want you to feel it
stop detaching from your dreams stop
avoiding that anxious scary feeling of
thinking how hard it's going to be and
thinking how great it's going to be
because most people just they don't even
think about it because it causes too
much nerves i'm like
dancing those nerves a little bit let
them come up for you because that's fuel
man
that's fuel it's like less brown
toddlers you got to be hungry
you'll never be hungry if you don't
visualize it see it feel it and want it
rule number seven take care of your
health i've always
really worked extremely hard to maintain
an incredible level
of energy in my mental body my i'm sorry
in my you know mental emotional physical
spiritual being
just trying to do everything i can from
the way that i work out to what i
consume to what i don't consume
to how i rest to how i meditate to how i
recover like everything in my life has
always been about how do i bring the joy
and if i'm going to generate the energy
i want to create for you guys how do i
do that specifically
well i've always got these routines and
everything else but what happened this
year
i was kind of had my health taken away a
little bit in
mid uh october i got pneumonia
and tonsillitis at the same time
while i was on the road doing multiple
four-day
and multiple five-day events where i'm
kind of the lead trainer
and that kicked my butt and i'm still
honestly recovering from it
like i'm i'm still feeling it i'm still
feeling heading into
the final part of this year i'm still
recovering uh don't worry
clean bill of health doctors like you're
good to go they're just your body's
maybe recovering you'll be
tired for a while and i made it 41 42
years
without feeling fatigue outside of times
of injury
you know i i don't think i've ever had
the flu
i don't really ever get sick when i get
sick it's like
sniffles um but this one was something
it just smacked me i mean i was down and
out it's why i feel like i'm way behind
on
my episodes for you all um it's why i
feel like we're launching a few things
in january that i'd hope to launch in
you know october so that like
taking care of my health is always been
a priority this year
i learned what it feels like when it's
gone and many been with me for a long
time
that happened in 2011 when i had my
brain injury
and i snapped my wrist and my ribs and
my hip um
so i'm not you know new to pain i'm not
new to being sick but this was the first
time
where i also with the sickness lost
motivation
you know where it was like even when i
had like when i was really sick in the
past of my life
i would still like wake up in the day
and i'd prime my mind
get excited about what's to come and
just go this year
there was about the last two months i
really had to work on that there were
plenty of days i was just like
ugh not because i didn't love my life or
i wasn't grateful
or present you've been there before like
when you just
you physically feel terrible it is hard
to get your mind right rule number eight
build a plan
a lot of people have self-doubt in their
lives because they don't have clarity
for
what they want a lot of people wander in
a situation and they have a lot of
self-doubt because they didn't sit down
and plan it out
they didn't prepare they didn't ask
mentors or
model others or do their research to
figure out okay i should do
a b c d and e in other words
if you don't know the steps to success
of course you'll have more self-doubt if
you don't have the plan
if you don't have the map if you don't
know what you're doing
of course you're gonna have more
self-doubt so part of it is just like
decide to build a plan even if you have
to ask for help and say hey guys
how would you do this what would be your
first step what would be your second
step
i'm always asking that even at this
stage of my career i'm still saying hey
guys
if you're going to launch this how would
you do it if you're going to promote
that how would you do it
if you're going to create this thing how
would you do it if you're going to build
this team or build that business
what would you do and i always try to
get the map
before i enter the woods so that i have
the steps i know the path
because if you can remove the doubt
about the path
you'll have more confidence in yourself
rule number nine want it i really
believe
most people are terrified of
embarrassment
they might call it something else
but they're scared of embarrassment i
just put this video out
where it starts for the first line is
you're not scared to start your dream
you're embarrassed to be seen starting
small
and it just blew up on social media for
us um i think i got more
direct messages on that one little post
than anything i've ever done
and uh people really resonated with it
and because if you think about the truth
about it is that's what it is for a lot
of people they don't
if they quit their job and they go to
start something new they don't want all
their former
you know people to see them doing
something that looks the
you know new and fresh and and maybe
ugly or not put together
they're scared to be embarrassed and
have other people
judge them they're scared they might use
different language well
you know you know they might say well
i'm just fearful but if you really dig
down the fearful most people are just
scared to be embarrassed
they're scared to try something and
obviously fail at it
and the perception of that failure
really shuts them down
so we have to ask different questions
and i ask this all the time
i literally use the word embarrassment i
said listen
i always say something like are you not
going to try this
before we even get to this like you can
see it you made it happen
are you not going to try because you're
scared of what somebody else might think
are you not going to try it because
you're scared of somebody of what
somebody else might think
i ask that all the time
and almost all the time people go
well you know i'm not scared but uh you
know i'm worried what my spouse will
think
i'm not scared but yeah you know the
people at work might think i'm a little
crazy
and i'll explore that with them because
if
we can't get them over that line of
embarrassment
and the willingness for trial and error
we won't get them to do anything and so
my way
through embarrassment for for
me is two different ways just depending
on who the person
is when i hear that someone might be
embarrassed to do something
um i'll often start with that past
attempt conversation
have you tried something like this
before and people were horrible to you
and they're always like well no i've
never tried this before oh so you're
making an assumption
that you'd feel uncomfortable but then i
also want to give them permission of
like
is this dream worth having a few people
think you're crazy
is this dream worth having a few people
think you're crazy
and i'll open up that dialogue well yeah
okay well who might think you're crazy
well my spouse is going to think i'm
crazy cool how are they going to
communicate that to you well they're
gonna call me stupid
have they ever called you stupid before
well no or yes they have
i say okay so you do you survive the
last time they called you stupid
would it be worth surviving it again if
they call you stupid
if you felt better because you actually
got momentum towards something that
matters to you
like oh yeah and listen
knowing that a big frame here
and helping people get over excuses is
getting them tied back to
is what they are after important i
brought that up earlier
how important is this to you do you
really want this
well if you said that's important isn't
it worth a little discomfort
haven't you been discomforted before
haven't you
felt judged and stupid before okay so
you know you'll survive that
now the question is so the question is
about survival right let's say yeah it's
not about survival
great question is about survival sounds
to me
like the real question
is whether you want it we know you'll
survive
i'm curious what if we know you'll
survive
what will it feel like if you're
thriving
would it be worthwhile to have a few
doubters
or look stupid or be seen as silly
if you woke up energized by what you
were doing
would that be worth it annual number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip
is honor the struggle honor the struggle
like so many people bemoan the hardship
and they hate it and i was saying you
know anything you
anything you apply hate to quickly dies
you got a dream and you're hating the
process you apply hate to the process
the dream's gonna die
you know it's like don't don't
you know be very be very careful of what
you put hate or
things to and most people do that with
hardship and i've always seen hardships
like i'm gonna honor this process
sort of it's a little samurai mentality
you know it's like
i'm gonna honor that this is difficult
because that is precisely what's needed
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get
motivated and watch a video you have a
35
chance of following through that's what
the science says but
when you write down what time what day
what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
you have to reframe confidence
a lot of people say well brad i'm just
not confident i wish i was more
confident i wish i had more fire i wish
i
believed in myself more i just it's my
doubt i always worry about myself i
never believe in myself i'm always
selling myself short and i always never
give myself credit i just quit
and maybe but i think what happens for a
lot of people is they just never really
learn what real confidence
is it's like they're not necessarily
without each other it's not like they're
necessarily mutually exclusive right
it's like sometimes the truth is you can
be confident but still have doubts about
capabilities
that makes you real it makes you a
non-egomaniac
because only superego maniacs have no
self-doubt
like only sociopaths lack enough
self-doubt
and so self-doubt can be okay what you
have to figure out is
what does confidence mean to you instead
of worrying so much about the doubt like
what's the opposite what's the other
part of that
what does confidence really mean to you
and we did the largest study that's ever
been done on high performers worldwide
and what we learned about is like the
most successful people in the world
the way they think about confidence is
is this simply this
their belief in their ability to figure
things out
so it doesn't mean they don't have
self-doubt they just believe i can
figure things out
give me enough time energy resources
mentorship support
and i can figure anything out and you've
got to start believing
that as much you spend time questioning
yourself you have to think okay
can can i remember that i've figured out
things in the past
that i wasn't prepared for that you've
done projects in the past
you've been in situations the past where
you had no idea how to handle it
but you figured it out take confidence
in that
next time you're going in a situation
and all you can do is think about
yourself think about yourself think
about yourself and freak out
what i want you to do is to remember all
of those times
where you did overcome the doubts did
overcome the anxiety
came you know overcame the lack of skill
or the unknowns and you still pulled it
off
and there's been more times in your life
that that happened
than you give yourselves credit for i
mean maybe you showed up that one time
at school and you were self-doubting but
people liked you and you were just fine
maybe that one time you went to that
project and you knew you didn't know how
to do it but by the end of that week or
the end that month
you figured it out you have to have a
memory
for the things that you did overcome as
much as you
worry about the things that you're
lacking in does that make sense
if all of your thought pattern is always
running on i lack i lack i lack i lack i
lack of course you're gonna self-doubt
all the time
to a degree where you stop but if you
remember oh wait yeah i overcame that
yeah and i learned that and i figure out
how to do that and that went just fine
and they were fine with me and i did
okay over there
if you can have that self-talk remind
yourself
of all the times you overcame what you
did not know
that will be more of a genuine
self-confidence that says you know what
i believe in my ability to figure things
out
even if i have some doubts about how it
might go or doubts about how things
might turn out
i do know that i will figure it out give
me enough time
energy effort resources and support like
i said that's genuine self-confidence
it's not like i know everything it's you
know what i'll figure it out
and that's all i'm asking for you so
even though you have doubts
next time you're going to the situation
where you have doubt i want you to say
you know what i'll figure it out i'll
figure it out
and trust in that
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there